hello friends how are you was so whether
you live in the United States or you
don't live in the United States you are
probably a hundred percent well aware
that the presidential election is
happening here in the US right now or it
already happened to depending upon when
you're watching this video let me tell
you what I am so excited it's gonna be
over because I cannot stand seeing any
more political pre-roll ads here on
YouTube and I cannot stand that my
entire social network is consisted of
every single friend acquaintances people
I'm not even sure why I'm friends with
on Facebook has turned into political
experts but what I want to know from you
guys is who are you gonna vote for so go
to the link below cast your vote are you
gonna vote for Obama are you gonna vote
for Mitt Romney
I just don't know on Wednesday I'll do a
recap video letting you guys know who
you voted for and we'll see how accurate
is the actual election and please guys
to be nice in the comments everyone is
entitled to their own opinion but I have
a feeling that there's some bytes that
are gonna break out so go at it if you
do live me on it's H and you are old
enough to vote get your little butt out
there goat a lot sway your opinions on
you you should vote for it's not what I
do
it's your decision get out go do it
see you guys Wednesday ah now the moment
that we've all been waiting for
iPad Mini